Taylan is in the van so the nice thing
about driving in a van is like it you're
driving it in your bedroom a brand new
person is on the beach viviana and blake
is broken oh god this is your bachelor
in paradise recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses and rosy hi you guys i'm
lauren zima
and i'm here with some roses in a
champagne glass to toast myself cuz got
a promotion at work yes I'm drinking my
rose a out of this champagne glass
because I want to celebrate myself and I
don't feel bad doing this you are your
own biggest cheerleader you have to make
the life you want and I did you guys yes
I got a new position at Entertainment
Tonight I am now a correspondent on the
broadcast and I'm happy for myself and
I'm proud of myself and I worked really
hard to get here and I'm also bringing
this up not just to toot my own horn - -
but also to seriously a shirt and tell
you guys that roses and Rosie is not
going anywhere
we are still filming this it is my
favorite thing so you know don't worry I
mean I figured out a way to get paid and
drink at work so I'm not throwing that
away make your own life I came here to
ask you
you would leave paradise with me today
back to the show
so speaking of back Dean is back we knew
he was we were left on a cliffhanger
last week and now we're going to see
what will happen with Dean and Kayvan
what will Kalyn do there's an easy
choice here and a difficult choice
seriously as Kalyn has put it several
times she's making an easy choice or a
hard one the perfect guy or the problem
guy Connor or Dean even Dean seems
shocked that Kalyan is entertaining the
idea of leaving with him in his van he's
like okay believe you're talking about
convinced you used to be like no idiot
you know this would happen when I came
back drink every time Connor says the
right thing
Connor is telling Kalyn everything she
ever wanted to hear Dean say that he's
here for her I don't want it to be over
that he sees a future with her he's
yours
outside of paradise he also reminds
Cailin that Dean dumped her on her
birthday it was on your birthday two
actions really speak louder than words
and remember it was only an episode or
two ago that Kalyn herself said she and
Dean would not work outside of paradise
you know she's like that chapter was
closed and Connors saying why would you
reopen it and she's saying because Dean
came back and he opened it no close the
book throw it in a trash can light the
trashcan on fire use that fire to keep
yourself warm in your new life but you
know I think we all sense which way this
was gonna go and that's the direction of
four wheels and a sliding door I mean
Connors not worried and I think he
should be I do
Kalen and Dean did seem to have quite a
strong connection and I think Kailyn
sees Dean's gesture as big and romantic
and as a leap of faith and she's gonna
take that leap too hey you're young why
not do it babes go for it you've got no
responsibilities living the bad no way
we'll save this do you just kind of
doing that thing where the bad boy says
he's ready to be good for you I did it
for you I'm gonna change the name and I
want to take a moment to talk about how
freaking dangerous that is no I don't
want you to change for me I want you to
evolve for yourself and that I want you
to come to me as a whole in complete
person that I can join up with not try
to help fix okay great Izzy I don't have
time to figure you out that's for you to
do just say but Dean is saying some
things that Kailyn is liking and you
know he's saying them all with a smile
drink every time Dean says something
with a smile
that you decided to come talk to me I
did it for you I'm gonna change the name
I'm not like I said I'm not saying it's
gonna be easy coming out of this but
we're definitely gonna have like things
to work on myself mostly
big ol noggin ears continue to challenge
you don't get me wrong yes ma'am and you
know believe it or not blink is the
voice of the people he calls this out
he's like Dean is just so charming I
mean I think Dean is incredibly charming
you know once again Blake's like the
girlfriend Dean he's just so charming
right he's charming and disarming it's
alarming just whether or not he can
actually that's the difference
do you guys think Dean is sincere in
what he's saying or is he just smiling
through what he's saying or does he
believe he's sincere in the moment but
ultimately will be unable to follow
through let me know in the comments
below you leave with me
kaylynn decides to become cave and make
it official she's gonna live in the van
with Dean a bedroom on wheels where you
can make ramen it's there a wine fridge
in the van
they'll be my first question and this
struck me Dean says that Cailin leaving
with him is the best decision she's ever
made Dean I actually think you're a
fairly self-aware person you seem to
know that you don't have it all figured
out when it comes to relationships do
you really think that going with you and
the van is the best decision it would
separate me
you yourself said you weren't sure she
would or should do it what do you guys
think what's going with Dean in the van
the best decision Kalin's ever made
so Kalyan has to go tell Connor and she
like puts her hand in his leg and she's
like I gotta go
[Music]
and if I were Connor would have said I
know you were just making out with Dean
McCotter takes it in stride and cheers
to Connor and drink every time he said
he was blindsided as much as she was
blindsided this is even more blindsiding
to me or his mind was blood to me this
is mind blowing
well Connor even here talen is the voice
of the people she says what we're all
thinking and I quote it doesn't make
sense does it make sense but she's going
I mean we're wide and we're only on the
first storyline story why a story time
for wine okay best decision I've ever
made
thought I'd be grinding over game so
Kailyn and Dean leave and we have two
people leaving in a car that never
happens
how about higher yeah oh no I'm
literally just like totally out of it
right now but finally onto a different
to people katieandchris things are not
going well for Katie and Chris did you
guys struggle to understand what Katie
and Chris's issues were I did Chris
doesn't seem totally into her there's
some things I feel like I'm still
missing
as I am
they both think something's missing
doing his date yet they both want to
work through it they go on a date to try
to work through it but I didn't totally
understand the resolution that they came
to are you holding out for the next
person that walks down the stairs no
don't wait on me past that just me I
like them both they both seem great and
Katie's gorgeous by the way I mean I
when she was getting ready for her date
and that golden hour lighting I was
struck I was shook I was shaken I fell
to the floor she's unbelievably
beautiful but not unbelievably clear on
what's to happen with Chris drink for
the confusion Matt Matt Matt Matt this
poor guy he's gonna love triangle
between Sydney and Bri
but there is a bit of clarity on who the
new play boy's paradise is it's not
blank it's not Dean it's Matt Donald
everybody yeah who knew this guy he's
gone from being unwilling to go in for a
first kiss to being the mister that
Sydney wants to massage that Bree wants
to hot tub with okay Blake calls him the
Playboy of paradise so here's head he's
the new Playboy of paradise I honestly
think Blake gave him that title cuz he
was just real happy to get the get the
vibe off himself you know he's like that
guy that guy with two girls that guy
Matt not Blake Blake good that's bad
[Applause]
he's still pretty innocent though it's
like he's got this gorgeous blonde in a
hot tub with him and he's blowing
bubbles
Oh Matt and you know at this point some
of the Paradise math isn't making sense
to me I mean I just want to like put
people together so that they can be with
someone and try to work it out
Connor so lonely why doesn't Connor just
go with Bri and that was Sydney but no
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving and you know what it's giving us
again this season a totally new human I
mean we thought Christian was unfamiliar
we thought T chuan was a fresh face i
wrote down who the is revient i mean i
have never seen this woman before not on
a night one not in a cast photo she
could have never been on any of the
shows before and they could have dropped
her in paradise and I would've just said
I mean I believe it I've got to believe
you guys cuz that's what you're telling
me but tell me this you guys have you
ever seen her before
I can't drink every time somebody calls
revient by the Revie wrong name nice to
meet you Reb IANA comes the unexpected
lady warrant we weren't ready what's her
name's Ruby onna she just said to call
her riff ready ready I'm ready
unfortunately I think Raven is enough
Ravi Ravi Ravi Ravi Ravi yen revient by
the way I feel we're missing out on some
familiar faces remember Heather from
Colton's season the one who had never
been kissed why is she not in paradise
she got her first kiss on that so she
could have taken it to the next step on
paradise that's the storyline I was
invested in who is ready yet
but she seems nice and she goes on a
date with oh my god my notes
autocorrected and her name is not right
at any point on this paper it says
Regina goes on a date with God poor
Revie and Jena revient and Connor go on
a date and I was a drink for every piece
of headgear they're wearing okay what's
a balloon animal on a helmet oh but you
know just like Kaelyn had to do when
Dean dumped her Connors got to move on
for being dumped by Kalyn got a move on
yeah and so Connors gonna move on by
making out with I it says retina it's
good they're kissing
but it feels too late in the game for
this to become a real thing doesn't it
let me know in the comments below but
over to something that is quite
significant Demi and Christian how have
y'all been how's your relationship been
it's been definitely an interesting we
know these two are in love but they
still have some things to work on in
their relationship drink every time they
mentioned love languages Jamie and I we
have different ways of showing like how
we feel I'm very affectionate I'm more
physical
she doesn't like too much like too much
love you don't like affection physical
but not touchy-feely with anyone I've
never been with someone
was very physical touchy Demi and
Christian have different love languages
Christian likes physical touch that me
does not it has everything to do with me
being comfortable with being gay around
people and Demi also opens up very
beautifully about just trying to work
through the fact that she's kind of a
newly out person and she is still
getting comfortable with people's
perception of her dating a woman and how
that will be seen in the world
Demi thank you for sharing your story
and we love and support you that's all I
have to say about that her and Christian
go on a date they have a cleanse
literally they have some good talks
adult delete I know that you are touchy
person yeah and I'm not it's wonderful
Cheers
[Music]
and from adulting to high school tisha
will you go to the Paradise prom with me
John Paul Jones is trying to show taste
show he cares so he takes her to a
Paradise prom this was cute I know I had
turned a bit on JPJ but he does still
have some endearing qualities I think
the pressure of Paradise got to him and
he did apologize for some of his actions
on Instagram though Derrick path noted
that he should have apologized
personally to the people that he hurt
what do you think could he agree with at
this point Derrick at JPJ we still have
the tell-all to get to
he's taking her to prom for the first
time I guess he should ever went to prom
which is wild but it's cute and they
dance though you know we can't get
through a JPG date without a bodily
function so he lets out a big old burp
[Music]
and we're all dancing except to Sydney
and Matt of course maybe he doesn't
dance maybe he's got to leave room for
Jesus what he dances maybe he thinks his
mom would not approve of him slow
dancing with a girl I don't I'm not sure
does talk about his mom a lot huh I mean
all my love to the moms but I wouldn't
call that sexy to bring up your mom I
want to so when you're starting to date
Blake to teach us how to do this yeah
Anisha does seem to be growing in her
affection for JPJ she just finds really
funny you know I mean he makes her laugh
drink for every time he makes her crack
up
[Music]
I therefore crown you the Queen
and from a success to mess Blake also
decides to create a date or Christina
[Music]
first of all John Paul Jones went all
out with a prom I think Blake put
together some pillows and a snack plate
which I mean I'm not gonna complain
about but at the same time go big or go
home
that phrase brings true you want like a
pillow
I wrote down he makes some efforts to
put together a date for Christina who is
you know as Blake has realized the one
that what you do for the one snack plate
he says he sees Christina as the mother
of his children about Christina as being
the mother of my children as his wife as
being my wife but it is undeniable
until christina denies it
on the date she is straight up with him
and says look I just can't get there
I cannot bear your children and
seventy-six thousand and four friend
ship roses later Christina leaves
paradise what did you guys think should
Christina have left yes she should have
left the answer is yes we all agree okay
and should wake his sad Blake again he's
got some sad to freaking out too
delusional I think he's not broken
and at last blake chooses to leave
paradise - do you think he should have
gone let me know in the comments below
yes he should have gone what cause Mike
Horstman says he went to Paradise and he
learned a lot at what cause but at what
cost not much I mean I don't think he
paid for the snack plate tell me what
you guys thought of this episode in the
comments below we only have a few hours
left on the beach how are you feeling
about this season overall and which
couples do you think will get engaged in
the end we are nearing the fantasy
suites of paradise who will put a ring
on it and also who should put a ring on
it any couples you think will get
engaged they are not ready to let me
know in the comments below as always
love you guys so much thank you thank
you thank you unendingly for your
support I love hearing from you on
Twitter on Instagram and I'm really
excited for my next chapter of evolution
and growth but again I'm not going
anywhere
love you so much
or old Lorenzini proud to be a TT
[Music]